ich habe gar nicht geschlafen hi
herzlich willkommen zu diesem blog leute
ist der erste seit längerer zeit hatten
ganz bestimmten grund ich fange jetzt an
zu arbeiten beziehungsweise ich mal ein
praktikum für mein studium da das mache
ganz spannend ist dachte ich mir einfach
machen jetzt wirklich noch jemand abholt
werden also besser ich freue mich
wirklich gesehen hat wenn du mensch
erfolgt bin ich ziemlich spät dran heute
mein vater praktikumstag und leute es
ist wie ihr vielleicht 1928 ich hab das
alles trug ihr auf dem tisch muss noch
packen und werde in einer - auch gut
hallo der praktikant ist da hallo
irgendjemand ins volk liebte ihn morgens
kollegen arbeitet dafür ist mein
arbeitsplatz und ich mache jetzt einmal
ein weiteres kleines für weniger arbeit
und bugs der arbeite und zeigt so leute
ich bin jetzt bei meinem chef und das
ist kein gerät das strom
ich arbeite nämlich bei guten morgen
internet unter anderem und wenn ihr so
der praktikant heißt ich mache zum
beispiel leuten flaschen auf die
moderatoren südamerikanischer weise
sturm waffe und was machen kaffee
es ist ok und am neuen becker ganz
ehrlich das wirklich ernst
was meinst du bist ganz kelly immer die
brille ab na ja und so schön von mir
gesehen lassen kelly
wer da hinten hatte ausgegeben
der berg ist im keller prämie verrät
aber auch zum verwechseln ähnlich
die kontrolle durch
verliert sie in einer anderen funktion
ist die 1
ich habe richtig richtigen auftritt und
zwar möglich karten rhein zeitung
[Musik]
leute wie habe ich die sachen eine dem
menschen wie dem kasten jetzt erstmal
energie cottbus aus düren
übrigens ein zweiter tag hier heute und
[Musik]
abonniert mit wie würdest du deine
arbeit bei guten morgen herr zu
schreiben
nico sehr aufregen ich habe einen roman
ich frage ihn so leute ich wurde die
längste verärgert ich hab mir robert
geschnappt und wir ärgern jetzt zurück
[Musik]
falls die karte einfach nicht lassen
die walliserin unis ich glaube ich dass
kopfhörer leidet wenn ein echter kröten
[Musik]
foxconn in china ganz schön eklig dass
er sich mit dem mädchen getroffen hat
glock ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
vielleicht noch mal wenn es gut ankommt